You know what?
We ended season 5 on a HUGE cliffhanger.
You want to find out whether, you know, Captain Holt becomes a commissioner or not,
I promise you, that will be answered in the first episode.
We will find out and then now that, you know,
Jake and Amy are married, we're gonna see where this relationship goes. You know what I'm saying?
And I'm ready for more high jinks, more stuff with the crew.
It's just gonna be insane. More– more and better.
All of us are really thrilled to be on NBC. I think
we've always had those roots in our show because they produced our show from the get-go.
I am personally really excited about being able to say bad words and then have them be bleeped out?
Yeah.
I think that's just, like (chef's kiss)
Yeah, it just feels... it's– it's beyond. I mean, it was such a, like, unexpected,
surprising outcome to that whole two days.
And yeah, like, somebody said they've always produced our show so it's a bit of, like, 'going home' in a sense.
It's great. We're so excited, and they're excited, and everybody's excited.
Excitement abounds.
Abound.
Abound
The new season holds many fun stories.
(laughs)
Obviously, we're gonna pay off the cliffhanger with Captain Holt.
We're gonna find out whether or not he got the big promotion as commissioner.
We're gonna see what married life holds for Jake and Amy.
We're gonna see Rosa's
newfound love life continue.
I'm sure we're gonna see Charles, infatuated with food and being slightly weird, but lovable.
(laughs)
It's gonna be good. We're excited. There's a lot of fun stories coming.
I would hope that we would have some amazing guest stars,
as well as the continuing foibles of our squad.
Nothing is... If it's not broke, we're not gonna fix it. We're a lot of the same
I think that
NBC now allows us to, like, use bleeps for, like,
(whispers) profanity.
Not that– that's not what we're pushing here, but like sometimes, you just gotta, just– you gotta say it.
More of the same, like, we're really excited.
Oh my god, you know it's weird because I'm a comic-con vet.
I've been here since, like,
2010, with the
Expendables and all three of them, and and then all the I hosted the Netflix panel last year but to be back because my show
is now on NBC. We're back to life we're back from the dead.
It's absolutely amazing and we took a bus down here from LA and it's been a party the whole time.
(sings in harmony)
I think our panel is gonna be really fun. Yeah, later. I think that'll be really fun
Our fans usually have really great, weird, cool questions during Q&As.
So I'm psyched for that.
And I heard there was, like, a line for our panel earlier.
Oh, that's cool.
That's cool.
There's also, and we're gonna do a giveaway of, like, signed,
like, scripts and DVDs and so I think people are gonna be excited to do that Brooklyn 99 trivia, that kind of thing.
We had a, you know,
the kind of a sad last day in season five weren't sure if we were gonna get picked up,
and we're like,
"But even if we don't, I'm sure maybe Hulu or Netflix will do it."
And then when that didn't happen, there was this feeling of,
"Wow, this is really over. This is done."
And then suddenly, you know, the Twitter and social media went
ballistic and suddenly we were saved.
It was like, you know being brought back from the dead, it was like, "Clear! STAT!"
It was just amazing, really good.
We're ecstatic to have a new lease on life.
You know, we thought that we weren't gonna be making the show anymore and NBC saved us.
Like, so many nights off the round table.
Because, you know what? The internet brought this thing back. The internet loves Brooklyn 99, and the internet runs Comic Con.
I mean, this is where the buzz happens. This is where you find out
who's who, what's what, what's cool over the next year and it's all about blogging,
it's all about putting this stuff down and, you know,
it's about the Facebook and Twitter and Instagram, and this is what it is.
And it's funny how I saw
someone cosplayed me as Terry Jeffords with the suspenders and tie, and I retweeted it,
I'm going, "Only at comic-con."
It's incredible. We didn't think we'd be around, let alone at comic-con. So we're thrilled.
We're thrilled with the outpouring of love and support we've had from our fans. Thank you very much.
I mean just just the outpouring, the unapologetic
fandom here is the best.
I was a nerd when I was a kid. I was into Stephen King and horror comics and and I was as passionate as
many– everyone here is about their particular show. So I feel at home.
It's incredible. I mean
We've done promotion for the show before over the last few seasons, but this is out of this world.
I didn't know how huge, I mean, I'd read about it,
I heard about it, but I just thought it was kind of like in one building or something.
Oh my god, the city of San Diego.
Comic-con has taken over the whole city. It's amazing. We had no idea. Well, we met the people from Doctor Know.
Doctor Who.
Doctor Who?
Doctor Know Who.
(laughs) Who knows?
But here's the deal we're both huge fans of a show called Broadchurch, in which
the people who are behind this show are all– and we were we were both like, "Oh my god,
We love you," and this is what's cool: they said, "we love Brooklyn 99." It was so cool. That was really great
I actually said to her, "I can–" Amanda, I think her name is?
The lead? I can't remember her name.
Be careful.
Yeah, here I go stepping right into it some more I said, "Oh, I'm so excited for your role in Doctor Know!"
But I was thinking about Broadchurch. I felt like a big dummy, but anyway.
So you planted the seed, thanks a lot.
We have no idea.
We're waiting. We don't know we haven't read a script yet
But I'm assuming it's gonna be very good.
(laughs)
I don't think it'll be dramatically different, if it's different at all. I'm not sure. I haven't– we have not seen a script.
We don't know Dan Goor and his guys are–
and Andy, they're all putting it together at this point. They're a little tight-lipped.
We'll have our first table read on the 8th of August.
August 8th, yeah
And then we'll then we'll know a little more. But NBC is old home for me,
I mean, my dad was on NBC forever
And I was on NBC for a few years years before you were born,
I imagine, but at any rate–
So we're– I'm thrilled to be back and and we're just thrilled to– we're thrilled to be moving on. Fantastic.
We've been welcomed with open arms.
Yes we have.
And we're very happy about it.
Ten out of ten.
"Ten out of ten," nailed it.
A hundred percent.